[Musique]
bienvenue sur les plateaux data ni
d'interdire il y a une grosse actualité
dont la presse française ne parle pas
c'est sur les ovnis ce le courrier
international il consacre sa une cette
semaine sous le titre faut-il avoir un
peu peur des ovnis en effet le 25 juin
le pentagone a rendu un rapport sur le
sujet il me dit pas que les
extraterrestres existent ni qu'ils sont
parmi nous mais il reconnaît que parmi
les nombreuses vidéos filmées par des
pilotes de chasse depuis 2004 et
montrant des tranches d'appareils
volants dans le ciel à des vitesses
phénoménales ou effectuant des
manoeuvres dont nous sommes capables
il y en a cent quarante-trois que le
pentagone est incapable d'expliquer ce
qui fait quand même beaucoup
assez pour que les médias américains
prennent les ovni au sérieux et pour que
nous puissions en discuter aujourd'hui
avec nos quatre invités s'en est bien
sûr les 4 le premier c'est jacques
arnould ingénieur agronome historien des
sciences et théologie un catholique vous
êtes chargé de mission pour les
questions éthiques au cnes le centre
national d'études spatiales
vous avez lu le rapport du pentagone il
fait 9 pages
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose de
véritablement nouveau là dedans
à part le fait que c'est une des
premières fois peut-être même la
première fois que le pentagone
communique sur ce sujet la nouveauté je
reviens dire c'est justement sa brièveté
vous venez de dire neuf pages donc tout
le monde peut livre assez rapidement et
puis il ne ne sommes pas par beaucoup de
données il n'a somme pas par des
conclusions définitives
en réalité comme vous l'avez dit il
ouvre le sujet en disant il y a des cas
que nous mettons au devant de vent sur
scène et nous ne connaissons pas la
réponse donc c'est une manière je trouve
de plus tôt de susciter la recherche de
dire il y à du travail de recherche à
faire et ça c'est à mon sens d'un
grandes nouveautés venant du pentagone
bien sûr oui c'est de donald trump 1
quand il était président qui avait donné
six mois
au pentagone pour faire état de ses
connaissances mais quelle vaillant vous
travaillez depuis 15 ans comme
consultant pour le gepan groupe d'études
et d'informations sur les phénomènes
aérospatiaux non identifiés qui dépend
du cnes et qui étudie les ovnis et
informe le public à leur sujet alors ce
rapport du pentagone qu'en avez-vous
pensé vous bien je rejoins tout à fait
l'avis de jacques la grande nouveauté
c'est le changement de ton c'est à dire
que l'on tend la main au témoin et en
particulier on arrête de penser que ce
sujet est un non sujet et ça rien que ça
c'est énorme
gabriel chardin vous êtes physicien
directeur de recherche au cnrs
vous êtes président du comité très
grandes structures de recherche depuis
très grandes infrastructures de
recherche depuis 2014 et la mission
d'interlocuteurs espace avec le cnrs
vous avez été confiée à partir d'octobre
ce rapport du pentagone je ne suis plus
dans le comité mais le président du
comité mais actuellement je suis revenu
dans un laboratoire d'astrophysique
mais j'ai eu les deux postes que vous
indiquez ce rapport je les lui comme vos
autres invités il est très court
effectivement si on enlève page de garde
des annexes ça ça fait un moins de sept
pages effectivement il ya un ton
probablement sans que à certaines
époques les pilotes en particulier
pouvait voir leur carrière endommagé six
rapportaient des faits de d'observations
d'ovnis et là effectivement on voit
qu'il ya une certaine incitation à être
exhaustif dans les rapports donc c'est
effectivement une modification de deux
tons même si sur le fond il n'y a pas
énormément
deux choses nouvelles thierry gaulin
vous êtes professeur
d'histoire-géographie vous avez été
intervenants de premier niveau
c'est-à-dire enquêteurs pour le gepan et
vous êtes président de l'association
ovni languedoc vous avez écrit plusieurs
livres sur les ovnis le dernier ces
ovnis en méditerranée qui est paru aux
éditions lacour ce rapport du pentagone
il a fait beau vos délice ou pas non il
n'a pas de famille délice mais je
rectifierai quelque chose mon troisième
livre est publié à l'oeil du sexe aux
éditions de l'oeil du 5e rang pas de
chance aujourd'hui c'est pas grave non
après le rapport est intéressant dans la
mesure où effectivement une grande
institution des états unis reconnaît
qu'il ya quelque chose qui volent dans
l'air et que leurs instruments de mesure
leurs radars étaient peuvent aller
capter donc il ya vraiment un problème
est qu'ils se posent à quand à dire ce
que c'est bon ça c'est autre chose on
est d'accord
alors parmi ces films qui d'ailleurs
seront passés depuis dans l'émission la
célèbre émission 6 10 minutes aux états
unis il y en a d'ailleurs qui fait aussi
la couverture du spiegel
parce qu'à part en france tout le monde
parle mais on reviendra sur la question
française mais je vais vous montrer
juste ce petit film là par exemple qui
est passé sur six 10 minutes qui fait
partie des films authentifié voilà vous
l'avez sous les yeux voilà ce que ce qui
a été filmé par un par un chasseur
américain
et voilà ce que le pentagone déclare ne
pas pouvoir expliquer on parle
aujourd'hui aux états unis de phénomènes
inexpliqués et pas d'objets volants non
identifiés un quoi c'est quoi la
différence d'ailleurs à vos yeux j'ai
qu'arnold un phénomène n'a pas
nécessairement un objet derrière lui
voilà qu'un objet l'objet est un
phénomène et puis un objet qui volent
est un phénomène et c'est pourquoi le ps
depuis très longtemps utilisent plutôt
la dénomination dénomination de
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
qui est plus large qui fait que c'est
pas forcément par les extraterrestres
c'est pas forcément même un objet en
tout cas un objet proches et je crois je
crois que vu justement à l'ignorance qui
la nôtre par rapport à l'ensemble de ces
phénomènes le terme de phénomène est
quand même plus adapté parce que
le réduire immédiatement un objet
signifierait que nous avons déjà des
idées plus précises que celles que nous
possédons alors comment expliquez vous
le fait que tout ça n'intéresse pas les
français
ou en tout cas que les médias français
n'en font pas et qu on a vu la
couverture du spiegel
aujourd'hui à washington ça bruisse de
rumeurs il ya eu des articles des
émissions absolument partout en france
rien si vous regardez dans le monde
on ne parle jamais des ovni dans le
monde par exemple mais je vais me
taquiner frédéric taddeï c'est que
beaucoup de français ont regardé une
autre chaîne de télévision il ya
quelques mois ont vu la série ovni ils
sont dit maintenant j'ai tous les
éléments possibles plus nécessaire
d'aller voir voir ailleurs pour voir des
informations mais mes collègues et mes
collègues du geipan savent que les
journalistes ont pas l'air de prendre ça
au sérieux alors justement vos collègues
du japon vont peut-être avoir la la
solution enfin la réponse mickey michel
vaillant pourquoi est ce que la presse
française ne prend pas les ovni au
sérieux alors que les américains
commencent à les prendre au sérieux la
question est assez troublante en fait
c'est vrai que nous du point de vue du
geipan et je réponds à titre personnel
intentions on a quand même ce prisme
c'est à dire que l'on observe les
phénomènes et la presse au quotidien et
au quotidien c'est à dire que l'on va
chercher dans la presse les les
informations qui ont pas on a quand même
tendance à observer que moi je réduirai
pas autant que la presse française quand
même en part
alors ça fait peut-être pas les gros
titres les plus gros titres mais il ya
une montée en puissance qui est très
importante honnêtement et ça a commencé
comme vous l'avez souligné avec la série
avoue c'est à dire que on a eu ce jeu ce
focus quelque part en début d'année qui
est totalement indépendant et on savait
déjà qu'ils allaient ce rapport qui
allait sortir
on savait déjà que effectivement il y
avait une détente qui était amorcée
depuis un ou deux ans puisqu'on avait vu
ses fameux film dans le effectivement on
a fait l'analyse et qui sont repris par
le rapport
et depuis j'ai envie de dire ça monte
crescendo ça n'a pas cessé
alors il ya quand même deux ans il ya
quand même rien eu dans la presse
française sur la publication du rapport
par exemple à par courrier international
jeu non je ne pense pas je vous donnerai
des références mais franchement non il
ya eu quand même des retours de la
presse
alors c'est moi qui fait d'erreur
gabriel chardin vous il ya quand même
une différence de perception dans les
médias français
à vrai dire je ne sais pas exactement
quelle est la perception
je pense on dit souvent que les
scientifiques sont très réticents par
exemple vis-à-vis des phénomène ovni
je pense que le scientifique il regarde
mais il essaye de se voir ce qui est
convaincante pas et de ce point de vue
il est presque étonnant qu'il n'y ait
pas plus de phénomènes non expliquée sur
la période indiquée qui est relativement
récente 2004 à 2020
et dans les catégories qui sont utilisés
dans le rapport on voit que healy a en
particulier ce qu'ils appellent kloter
in space c'est à dire donc le
l'occupation de l'espace par des
différents objets de fait qui est de
plus en plus par exemple du trafic
aérien mais aussi des ballons des drones
etc et donc barré assez inévitable que
il ya un certain nombre d'observations
qui soit difficile à interpréter
thierry gaulin oui je serai peut-être
moins gentil que les autres invités je
dirais que là le fait que la presse ne
parle pas beaucoup d'ambiance de ruches
au logis tient à la fois du traitement
de l'information que certains médias
l'ont fait par le passé qu'ils n'étaient
pas du tout sérieux et cela tire aussi à
l'attitude d'une bonne partie du petit
monde du saut logique qui prête à
sourire bien évidemment du fait de ces
agissements et déclarations à tort et à
travers
après je nuancerais ça aussi parce qu'il
y a des la presse écrite notamment qui
ferait de temps en temps des bons
dossiers lyonnais qui est sortie cette
année d'une de vos collègues sophie
boutboul ou d'ailleurs jacques arnould a
participé un i la presse écrite est
peut-être plus ouverte que les médias
audiovisuels à ce sujet et sont
généralement des bons dossiers
alors on l'a dit et en braquant
washington en ce moment enfin le monde
politique américain est très est devenu
très hauts revenus
friendly on va dire alors qu'ils étaient
très sceptiques et jusque là j'aimerais
bien savoir pourquoi qu'est ce qui a
changé pour que tout à coup les
américains est une curiosité
bienveillante à l'égard de ce fait ce
domaine une task force avait été nommé
par par donald trump il ya un an donc il
ya ce rapport qui vient de sortir il ya
eu l'émission sixty minutes s'il ya eu
des des articles à peu près partout il
ya 30 ou 40 ans l'un d'eux vous l'a dit
on risque et son risque et son poste si
on croyait aux revenus à paris me carter
qui quand il était président avait dit
qu'il avait vu lui
un ovni mais à l'époque personne ne
prenait jimmy carter au sérieux mais
sinon c'était c'était c'était très
mauvais pour une carrière
comment ça s'est renversée semble que
vous posez la question je suis pas un
spécialiste de la gérer de la pensée
américaine parce qu'il ya vraiment une
question de culture américaine il y à 50
ans il ya eu des rapports extrêmement
alors là c'est justement des rapports
très lourd s'était pas neuf pages
énormément de données
tout ça pour dire aux gens circulez ya
rien à voir
pourquoi parce que il y as derrière ces
questions là et c'est très présent dans
le dernier rapport les questions de
défense nationale pas seulement bien
précise et pas seulement la défense de
l'espace aérien
mais une question de défense nationale
et dès lors qu'on touche avec et sur la
défense nationale ou et bien apparaître
immédiatement énormément de secret de
précaution et donc le choix il ya 50 ans
c'est dire comme ça dépend de la défense
nationale vraiment c'est circulez ya
rien à voir vous vous taisez donc
c'était un black out en réalité et ce
black out
comme toujours ça va pas changer du jour
au lendemain il faut des années pour que
les gens retrouvent une certaine un
certain intérêt retrouve aussi une
certaine liberté est évidemment en 50
ans ne serait ce que les médias le rôle
des médias le type de média ont
tellement changé que cette question qui
conti qui a toujours suscité l'intérêt
des humains on va pas faire de
l'histoire de la philosophie mais ça
fait 2500 au concert est ce ce genre de
questions si ce n'est plus donc c'est
normal que la saps ces présents et en
fonction des conditions médiatique de la
culture bien le phénomène reprend un peu
de vigueur en tout cas de figure
médiatique ou pas alors qu'en france je
pensé et mickaël expliqué il aurait été
toujours un intérêt de vue fonderie quid
du public et ça nous le geipan à des
indicateurs je crois qu'ils montrent que
montre bien cet intérêt constant et
parfois même un peu exagéré
trouvons-nous gens de l'espace parce
qu'on préférait qui s'intéressent à
d'autres choses qu aux ovnis bon mais
c'est comme ça et après bon évidemment
il ya il ya des phénomènes anecdotique
il ya une série télévisée
il ya un phénomène astronomique qui peut
être très important est vu par beaucoup
de monde alors brutalement mais dessus
je trouve que c'est très représentatif
pas seulement aux états unis de la
complexité cette question là est dans la
question de la défense
en france aussi existe également dans un
rapport déjà anciens c'était le focus de
ce rapport qui avait été mon rédigés par
des généraux et des scientifiques
donc voilà il s'agit de gérer cette
cette cuisine en fonction des époques en
fonction de ce que chacun aussi trouver
un intérêt à l'expliquer parce que
excusez moi je dis pas que c'est un
marronnier mais ça joue aussi un peu le
rôle de marronniers dans les médias oui
mais en même temps on a l'impression que
du fait que sur internet il ya
énormément de films comme ceux qui
passent derrière moi on en verra
d'autres au cours de cette émission et
non plus ne sont pas toujours expliqué
on a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement américain où les médias se
sentent obligés d'en parler on a vu
barack obama interviewé dans l'émission
late late show
avant même la publication du rapport qui
a dit exactement ce qu'il ya dans le
rapport
il a dit ben oui y'a plein de phénomènes
que l'on n'arrive pas à expliquer de la
confirmer avant même que le rapport
sorte mais néanmoins qu'est ce qui a
changé à votre avis michael valiante
l'ado au cours des 20 dernières années
et oui on sait on s'est beaucoup posé la
question en fait pourquoi ce rapport aux
maintenant qu'est-ce qui fait qu' il a
pu arriver
et quelles ont été les conditions qu'ils
ont permis je pense qu'effectivement il
ya 20 ans aurait pas été possible
peut-être malgré tout et ça ce n'est
qu'une hypothèse
le travail du geipan aussi je pense
qu'on a ces dernières années
eu un changement de sémantique on a
parlé tout à l'heure de hippies donc
deux en anglais c'est et en français ces
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
ne pas parler d'ovni c'est déjà plus
simple je pense pour toutes ces
catégories de personnes qui ne veulent
pas être associés à des phénomènes dont
tout de suite on dirait ce sont des
extraterrestres ce sont des objets avec
des pilotes derrière qui sont en train
de conduire et ça c'est un premier point
c'est à dire que quand on met un peu de
distance
quand on met un peu de prudence déjà
dans le dans la façon d'aborder le
phénomène c'est déjà un peu plus à m'en
parler
et puis ensuite et ça rejoint ce que je
disais en préambule il ya le respect
vraiment des témoins et ça je pense que
à l'échelle de a les trois générations
ça vraiment énormément beaucoup changé
c'est à dire que on pouvait il ya 60 ans
se moquer des témoins vous pouvez
effectivement rire des gens vous
souvenez de la soupe aux choux vous
pouvez effectivement trouvé totalement
niés et ridicule un témoin qui vient
rapporté son observation et qui pourtant
vous confie quelque chose qui est
précieux pour lui c'est une histoire
presque intime c'est quelque chose qui a
pu être violent dans sa vie quelque
chose auquel il ne s'attendait pas et il
faut vraiment le respecter et on
s'aperçoit ou avec l'expérience avec les
retours que l'on a eu que la plupart des
gens viennent sincèrement témoigner
très peu de très très peu de canular
très peu de mensonges et l'un dans
l'autre on a fait évoluer on en a fait
mûrir cette réflexion sur le témoin
comment le respecter comment le mettre
en confiance et essais pour moi qui est
très important sera pas c'est que
justement il souligne ce à dire qu'il va
souligner le fait qu'il faut protéger
les pilotes il faut protéger ceux qui
ont lu des choses pour les aider
finalement à témoigner à la fois
librement mais aussi à quelque part je
vais pas dire banalisée ces témoignages
mais à les rendre voilà les rendre norme
rohs presse dire que ce sont des
témoignages bizarre c'est sûr mais ces
sondes étaient match comme les autres et
il faut les traiter comme les autres
sans plus gabriel chardin
je dirais qu en particulier pour des
observateurs professionnels comme des
pilotes effectivement et il paraît
logique d'essayer de ne pas les
décourager leurs témoignages
et cette attitude me paraît tout à fait
correct après pour les gens qui sont au
sol
non non professionnels probablement il
se laisse un peu plus souvent trompés
par des lisons des phénomènes
qui peut être des ballons qui passe dans
le ciel où on sait qu'on est un petit
peu moins fiables probablement dans la
majorité des cas donc je crois
qu'effectivement ça a été dit c'est
c'est une ouverture plus grande qui
montrent que les gens sont un petit peu
plus décontracté vis-à-vis du du
phénomène et puis après chacun essaye de
d'en tirer la réalité que c'est à dire
qu'est ce qui se passe à quoi sont dues
ces phénomènes qui reste inexpliquée
thierry gaulin oui je ne sais pas si les
états unis viennent de découvrir qu'il
faut traiter les témoins avec respect
parce qu'on fait car il me serre en
france depuis depuis bien longtemps
c'est la base de notre travail avenue
languedoc
le recueil de témoignages et une enquête
mais c'est évident que ben qui est un
changement quelconque qui s'est passé un
moment donné peut-être tous les facteurs
que vous avez évoquées précédemment
on aboutit à une conjoncture où c'est
peut-être le moment effectivement pour
les états unis de passer à autre chose
ou alors si je rajoute avec un petit peu
de cynisme c'est peut-être le moment
bien tour de demander des fonds
supplémentaires pour la défense aux
états unis puisqu'il ya des choses qui
n'arrivent pas à identifier d'accès
d'anciennes alors vous et je voulais
justement il venir parce qu on se
souvient que la première époque des
ovnis 1947 c'est le début de la guerre
froide et il se trouve que aujourd'hui
où tout à coup on se remet à en parler
énormément
c'est peut-être le début d'une autre
guerre froide avec la chine ou avec la
la russie on voit bien qui en a acquis
un certain nombre d'articles aux états
unis qui disent attendait tous ces
phénomènes inexpliqués en fait c'est
forcément nos ennemis qui ont acquis une
supériorité technologique considérable
ce sont les chinoises ce sont les russes
et il faut les rattraper il faut mettre
plus d'argent sur la défense s'est
éteint ce que vous faites allusion
thierry gaulin ont eux on le lit dans la
presse américaine ça oui ça j'en doute
pas mais j'ai un peu de mal à croire que
la chine qui a trente ou quarante ans de
retour d'un de nombreux domaines
technologiques ou la russie qui peut
très bien avoir de l'avancé à 0,2 mais
beaucoup de retard dans d'autres
soit vraiment une demeure une menace
réelle pour la super puissance que sont
les états unis aujourd'hui
mais il n'était pas non plus du temps de
l'urss enfin il était un peu mais pas
tant que le racontait les faucons
américains qui demandait toujours plus
d'argent
elle a dès lors il l'était du fait de
leur nombre
c'est le nombre qui faisait leur
puissance et leur technologie depuis
depuis la course à la lune et depuis les
années 60 et la technologie a du retard
pendant la guerre froide effectivement
on comptait par exemple 73 qu'on a
quelque chose comme 450 soumaré chez les
soviétiques et 150 aux états unis c'est
le nombre qui faisait la terreur j'ai
gardé je suis parfaitement l'année ce
qui devait être fait mais là aussi on
est sur un jeu pas seulement de médias
mais un jeu politique
le ce qu'on a pu appeler est ce qu'on
n'a pas encore vu le fossé technologique
est un argument très souvent utilisé aux
états unis alors après quelle est la
réalité du fossé ça c'est tout le c'est
tout le jeu metal est qui est un jeu
d'influencé
nous le constatons et et nous en sommes
en même temps je ne dis pas les victimes
mais nous avons les échos de ce genre de
rapport qui vont effectivement dans ce
sens tu as une fois encore l'autre
qu'ils soient chinois qu'ils soient
soviétique où qu'ils soient and aliens
nous fait toujours un peu peur
donc il s'agit de gérer pour chaque état
la gestion de l'autre alors voilà
pourquoi pas via via des extraterrestres
nikkei gagnant alors j'ai une analyse un
peu plus ambigu peut-être mais j'ai
l'impression que effectivement c'est un
jeu politique bien sûr mais c'est aussi
une forme de rhétorique c'est à dire que
quelque part ce changement radical de
position
quand on voit leur apporte mon don de
l'époque qui disaient circulez ya rien à
voir il n'y a pas de danger pour pour
les états unis
prendre une position inverse aujourd'hui
on sait c'est louable c'est intéressant
ça permet je pense surtout et
essentiellement d'attirer des fonds
c'est probablement le chemin le plus
direct et le plus court pour trouver des
moyens de financer quelque part de la
recherche ou sur ce sujet il aurait dit
oui on va faire des analyses
je sais pas sur ces phénomènes qui sont
totalement inexpliquée je pense que ça
aurait été beaucoup plus difficile à
expliquer aux contribuables américains
là on est dans une forme amendée vie de
rhétorique dire qu'on va chercher des
moyens simples pour aller trouver du
financement etc plus et s'enfonce et
s'en allait effectivement trouvé des des
explications alambiquées parce que on ne
sait pas donc forcément
qu'est ce qu'on peut trouver deux
rapides et d'efficace gabriel chardin et
après on va faire une pause
eh bien disons effectivement je pense
qu'il peut y avoir des déserts penser
qu'ils sont purement budgétaire ça c'est
c'est assez clair mais on est en train
de parler là plutôt de d'expliquer des
observations d'expliquer le
l'accumulation d'objets dans le ciel
sans que ça soit a priori réellement un
changement sur les ovnis après le fait
de savoir si ça peut venir de la russie
ou de la chine je pense que les etats
unis aujourd'hui ne sont pas extrêmement
inquiets sur les objets qui passe au
dessus d'eux même s'ils peuvent vouloir
regarder un peu plus précisément un
alors en revanche quand on regarde à 100
nombre de films sur internet alors je
parle pas de ceux qui ont été commentés
par le par le pentagone mais si vous
regardez par exemple là tout de suite un
film qu'on a pu voir à la télévision
allemande
au journal télévisé parce que tout à
coup une caméra d'autoroute a enregistré
basse à regarder ça c'est impressionnant
ça voilà on l'a vu c'est un rayon de
lumière qui tout à coup se soulèvent un
camion 1
alors ça c'est passé à la télévision
elle marque et quand vous regardez ça
vous voyez quoi vous j'avoue que je vois
pas grand chose j'ai toujours un
problème avec ce genre de vidéo y
compris celles des américains pour sa
demande vraiment une face au genre de
choses vraiment un regard d'expert parce
que nous avons parlé a juste dit tout à
l'heure de ses pilotes qui sont
effectivement des observateurs
professionnel et j'ai eu il ya déjà
nombreuses années l'occasion de visiter
un des centres d'entraînement des
pilotes de l'armée française et ce
centre a en particulier comme mission de
sensibiliser les pilotes
on a tous les effets les faux amis et
les effets d'optique auquel il va être
confronté durant leur vie de pilote
donc je dis d'autant plus s'ils sont
d'autant mieux placé qui ont entraîné là
ils sont entraînés à être très très
attentif
enfin très prudent avec ce qu'ils voient
et vendu à discuter avec des pilotes
d'une compétence civile
ils vous disent la même chose parce que
ça fait aussi partie des blagues entre
pilotes
le jeune pilote il regarde il ya quelque
chose et et la plupart du temps si la
blague est bien préparé et bien les
jeunes pilotes pas encore expérimenté
donc ce sont c'est vrai que ce sont des
observateurs professionnels et surtout
expérimenté et et sensibiliser alors moi
qui ne suis rien de tout ça je toujours
du tour méfiance parce que je ne parle
même pas de bon le skip est de bricolage
derrière parce que nous le savons bien
au geipan il ya déjà longtemps que nous
travaillons sur les images nous recevons
les films ou de manière involontaire
mais même nommé nos instruments peuvent
être l'heureux eux aussi alors il faut
quand même beaucoup de prudence
enfin celui là il fallait parce qu'il
est passé à la télévision allemande ont
fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
merci on a identifié un peu plus de 500
depuis un an et demi les alertes
concernant les menaces de prédation sur
des entreprises françaises se
multiplient en vous avez un pays qui est
affaibli par une crise économique
majeure
ça intéresse les prédateurs parce qu'ils
savent que vous ne pourrez pas vous
défendre
ça peut le chacun pour soi dieu pour
tous actuellement dans cette guerre
économique il ya le darwinisme classique
et économiques et les gros mangent les
petits mais là on se trouve devant un
nouveau type de risque le droit est
maintenant utilisée par les états pour
aider leurs entreprises notamment à
affaiblir d'autres entreprises
étrangères
tous les gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
ministère de l'économie ne savent pas ce
que c'est qu'une entreprise puisse y ont
jamais mis les pieds
donc ne leur demandez pas défendre
quelque chose qu'ils ne connaissent pas
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer
cinq ans de psychodrame ça qu'on
négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prête le 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 états autres c'est
juste quelque chose d'inconcevable
l'angleterre 20 perd gros là nos amis
britanniques ont fait un choix en 2016
qui est un choix qui je pense va
impacter l'économie profondément sur les
prochaines années et va impacter des
générations les choses sont en train de
se caler de se mettre en place
est ce que les choses sont totalement
fluide réponse est non
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec jacques arnould
qui est chargé de mission pour les
questions éthiques au cnes le centre
national d'études spatiales avec michael
vaillant qui est consultant pour le
gepan le groupe d'études et
d'informations sur les phénomènes
aérospatiaux non identifiés qui dépend
donc du cnes avec gabriel chardin qui
est des physiciens et avec thierry godin
gaulin qui est en quête qui a été
autrefois enquêteurs pour le gepan et
qui est toujours président de
l'association ovni languedoc
parmi les choses qui ont changé il ya
peut-être le fait qu'aujourd'hui on sait
que notre univers contient des milliards
de galaxies alors abattu moment il ya
des milliards de galaxies peut-on encore
croire que l'on est les seuls dans
l'univers
en tout cas les seules doté d'une
intelligence gabriel chardin ce que la
probabilité ne s'est pas inversé en
faveur de l'existence d'extraterrestres
sur cette question là je pense qu'on
peut être beaucoup plus optimiste et
dans le sens à les deux galaxies en
galaxie c'est quand même ça serait très
difficile puisqu'on parle en millions
d'années lumière mais à l'intérieur de
notre galaxie environ un peu plus de 200
milliards d'étoilés très probablement et
là je dirais que on recherchera bien
dans les prochaines années des
indications d'existence de la vie à
travers diverses signature sur lequel on
pourra revenir mais il semblerait je
pense extrêmement normal ou ou probables
eux mêmes aux scientifiques qui puisse
exister un grand nombre de systèmes
planétaires qui puisse abriter la vie
sous une forme ou sous une autre lettre
d'accord miguel vaillant totalement et
c'est vrai que ça aussi ce concours
je pense à quelque part des glaces et le
le paysage et la réflexion sur sur ce
sujet c'est à dire ça concourt quelque
part une plus grande ouverture sur cette
idée qui pourrait y avoir des
intelligences et alors évidemment c'est
comme un château de cartes pour que ces
intelligences puisse effectivement nous
visiter il faut encore d'autres
conditions
mais mais du coup lorsque vous
consolidez cette base de réflexion qui
consiste à dire vous avez peut-être plus
effectivement de possibilité d'avoir des
planètes où il ya de la vie où vous avez
peut-être aussi plus de possibilités
aujourd'hui puisque le champ de la
réflexion scientifique continue à ceux à
se densifier dans ce domaine là sur
peut-être le voyage eh ben vous commencé
à amener des bris pour penser que
peut-être et des intelligences qui vont
aller jusqu à nous visiter
tiago là oui je suis d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit et on peut même aller un
petit peu plus loin parce que si on
cherche une vie qui n'est pas
intelligente par exemple on peut se
poser la question ne serait ce que pour
le système solaire il ya des
scientifiques qui pensent qu'un solde
par exemple pour rire recevez un embryon
de wismes de la dîme m même si l iguane
aussi sur cellulaire pardon après pour
le cantonne à présent de la vie
intelligente d'autres systèmes solaires
au galaxy je crois qu'il ya un danger
sur dans lequel on tombe assez
facilement c'est celui de l'entrepôt
centrisme il faut qu'on évite de alors
c'est très difficile mais il est logique
qu'elle que l'on pense avec notre avec
notre schéma mental avec nos acquis mais
ça ne veut pas dire que s'il ya une vie
intelligente ailleurs et même les mêmes
schémas mentaux les mêmes développements
technologiques les mêmes acquis
culturelles philosophiques ou religieux
soient les mêmes voulait dire que c'est
une facilité de l'esprit que de se
représenter toujours des extraterrestres
comme c'est des petits bonshommes au
fond alors on leur enlève les poils on
leur enlève le blanc des yeux mais au
fond ils nous ressemblent comme deux
gouttes
d'eau alors que il ressemble jamais à un
chat ou à ou à une araignée
après tout et pourtant les chats les
araignées sont nés sur terre tout comme
nous je sais pas si c'est une facilité
d'esprit mais en tout cas c'est comme ça
que nous raisonnons votre avis vous
voyez il ya plein de choses la première
c'est que jusqu'à présent nous n'avons
pas de preuve scientifique d'une vie
ailleurs deux formes de vie ailleurs que
sur terre et donc nous sommes face à
n'avons nous sommes tous seuls
donc quand une probabilité de ne pas
être seule commence à augmenter
évidemment nous nous tournons vers cette
affaire cette possibilité là parce que
il ya plus d'élément que de ce que la
situation dans laquelle nous vivons
depuis des millénaires
d'autant plus que nous risquons de
disparaître sans avoir la réponse parce
que trouver une que des extraterrestres
viennent nous visiter ou que nous les
rencontrions dans une autre planète
voilà là on aura la preuve que nous
sommes pas seuls mais en revanche avoir
la preuve que quelque chose n'existe pas
nous n'aurons jamais donc les
probabilités qui vont dans le sens où il
pourrait exister sont très attirantes
c'est le premier élément qui me semble
vain moi même qui pour pourquoi mon
intérêt pour cette question là ça doit
être un peu ça donc je m'imagine dans
une autre situation que celle dans
laquelle je suis aujourd'hui et alors
quand un autre pot morphisme
anthropocentriste enfin évidemment nous
n'avons pas d'autres repères que cette
planète que les êtres vivants qui sont
donc même notre imaginaire il doit bien
partir de quelque chose et il part de ce
que nous sommes de ceux que nous
expérimentons donc là aussi c'est normal
et en même temps il faut pas en avoir
peur
aujourd'hui l'entrepôt centrisme est
assez critiqués parce que nous voyons
les côtés négatifs d'un rapport à soi
incessants et de voir tout ramener à soi
mais en même temps il faut être
copernicien si vous me permettez
copernic a dit hé bien tout endroit de
l'univers peut être un centre c'est ça
le principe copernicien il n'y a pas un
seul sens qu il ya autant de centres que
d'endroits dans l'univers dont nous
sommes quand même un centre et nous
avons à assumer le fait d'être un centre
parmi d'autres partons de ce centre là
nous l'a encore n'ayant pas une espèce
de rejet total en dix ans là nous
n'existons plus il nous existons bel et
bien nous sommes nous sommes en train de
discuter entre êtres intelligents autant
que possible et pour l'instant on ne
sait pas si d'autres font la même chose
ailleurs dans l'univers donc assumons
notre existence alors aujourd'hui il ya
énormément de signes et on en voit
beaucoup sur internet qui pourrait
laisser penser qu'il ya effectivement
des phénomènes ou en tout cas des objets
volants non identifiés qui sont très
proches de nous dans notre ciel filmé
par nos avions et moi la question je me
suis toujours posé c'est pourquoi ne se
montre-t-il pas pourquoi pourquoi
reste-t-il ou essayent tentent ils de
rester caché alors est ce que c'est
parce qu'ils vont tellement vite qu'ils
n'ont pas le temps de s'arrêter pour
nous regarder mais ça reste pour moi un
vrai mystère vous auger panne
est-ce que vous avez une explication
pourquoi depuis si longtemps ces
extraterrestres
quand une telle supériorité
technologique pour être chez nous alors
que nous ne sommes pas chez eux
pourquoi ont-ils peur de nous au point
de ne pas vouloir se montrer nous si on
arrivait sur une planète habitée par des
fourmis qui vivent encore à l'âge à
l'âge des cavernes on s'arrêterait des
amicales vaillant oui je sais pas si
c'est le boulot du geipan de répondre à
ce genre de questions en tout cas à
titre personnel on peut on peut toujours
émettre des hypothèses mais ce sont plus
des hypothèses d'ordre philosophique
qu'autre chose puisque je rappelle que
quand même le travail des bouleaux du
geipan ça consiste à éliminer toutes les
hypothèses connu pour laisser ensuite un
ensemble de phénomènes inexpliqués
quelque part dans les mains des
chercheurs et il a effectivement ben
c'est aux chercheurs de continuer à
essayer de faire ce travail minutieux et
précis qui consiste à essayer de
détourner la réalité
alors après en terme d' hypothèse on
peut y aller
oui on peut imaginer que effectivement
l'ieee viennent ici et puis ils ont
aucun intérêt pour nous s'il y avait des
intelligences on peut imaginer qu
effectivement aussi on est 1 0 parce que
ça ça fait partie des autres hypothèses
dire qu'ils viennent
il s'intéresse à nous mais mille
interviennent pas on peut aussi imaginer
que et ça ça reste quand même possible
que ils nous ont pas encore découvert et
que peut-être qu'on n'est pas encore
tombé sur entre guillemets leur chemin
et ça me fait penser à woking ce qu'ils
disaient qu effectivement surtout il
faudrait peut-être éviter d'envoyer des
messages dans l'espace parce que
peut-être demain vous on serait
confronté à des extra terrestres qui
sont pas si sympa que ça finalement
bon chacun voit j'ai envie de dire un
peu là on est presque dans le domaine
des croyances midi à sa porte mais bon
je pense qu'on est dans franchement
aucune de ces hypothèses
on sera probablement si ça devait
arriver peut-être dans quelque chose de
plus plus envie du ou en tout cas plus
probablement moins tranchées voire et
est bon ça pouvait rendre à parler il ya
pas mal de choses à dire là dessus diego
là une explication au fait qu'ils ne
veuillent pas établir un contact
officiel
je n'aurais pas abordé la chose comme ça
parce que comme le disait michael on se
rapprocherait de la croyance dans la
mesure où on ne peut pas emporter une
preuve de l'existence d'extraterrestres
qui nous visitent ou pas d'ailleurs
on va se situer dans un domaine de la
croyance qui n'est pas la bonne façon
d'appréhender le phénomène ovni après
l'hypothèse extraterrestre fait partie
d'une autre d'une liste d' hypothèses
qui pourraient participer à
l'explication du phénomène
aérospatial non identifiés ou phenomenon
desbriel chardat en fait c'est un vieux
problème qui a été posée dès c'est une
question qui était posée dès les années
50 par le grand physicien et prix nobel
enrico fermi qui est d'estimer le nombre
alors évidemment le calcul est très
imprécis et s'est même pas vraiment un
calcul mais sert de probabilité le
nombre de civilisations qui à un moment
donné existe dans l'immense réservoir
des toiles de notre galaxie et il arrive
à un nombre énorme nous donc du coup où
sont ils
c'est la question qui pose sur une nappe
de papier parce qu'il fait là le calcul
avec ses collègues dans la dans la
cantine de fermilab celui qu'il est va
devenir tu vas voir son nom laboratoire
de fermi est bon la question existe
toujours dans l'équation dont on parle
on peut dire que les même si
effectivement on a encore détecté aucune
preuve de civilisation même d existence
de vie extraterrestre
les physiciens et les biologistes sont
prêts à mettre l'idée qu'il y en a plein
dans dans l'univers aller à une
civilisation atteindre un niveau de
civilisation technologique déjà comme le
nôtre ça c'est déjà une grande inconnue
arrivé en plus à passer le cap des
étoiles c'est à dire les proxima
centauri ça doit être à quatre années
lumière
ça c'est encore bien plus difficile
comme étape
et là on est on a tendance à dire qu'il
ya un très très grand gap
quelque chose qui empêche la majeure
partie de ses formes de vie de nous
rendre visible pourquoi à cause de
l'instabilité pour moi c'est à dire que
si vous êtes capable de lancer de
définir un programme spatial qui va vers
les plus proches étoiles alors vous êtes
aussi capable de bruit de la planète et
avant qu'on arrive à mettre en place un
système là on est dans le système
solaire c'est à dire les l'immédiat
voisinage au sens de la galaxie mais
atteindre et on les cent mille étoiles
les plus proches ça c'est vraiment un
autre challenge et malheureusement on
peut se dire que l'homme aura bien
dégradé la planète avant d'y arriver
mais vous avez parlé d'alpha du centaure
pour venir d'alpha du centaure il faut
combien de temps
il faut de ces aspects que ça se chiffre
en milliers en millions d'années est ce
que c'est possible que des êtres quel
qu'il soit puisse accomplir un tel
voyage parce qu'encore une fois c'est de
cela qu'on parle quand on montre tous
ces petits films
on a l'impression qu'il ya devant nous
la possibilité d'un vaisseau qui serait
venue de très très loin
est ce que c'est possible selon une loi
de la physique
il n'y a pas d'impossibilité de
principes clairement
après il faut focaliser les efforts sur
un programme comme extrêmement ambitieux
beaucoup plus difficile des milliers de
fois plus difficile que d'aller voir
pluton par exemple vous d'aller explorer
les lunes de saturne est donc d'autant
plus difficile sur le côté instabilité
focalisation des ressources pour arriver
à quelque chose d'aussi ambitieux est
beaucoup plus simple d'envoyer
effectivement des faisceaux lumineux ou
des faisceaux radio pour envoyer des
messages et voir si ça revient ou des
machines c'est à dire comme nous on
envoie des robots sur mars où des
machines on pourrait envoyer des robots
on a envoyé des jeux c'est plus céder
l'équivalent d'à dvd aux vagues va vingt
ou trente ans après ça paraît un petit
peu risible souvent les messages qu'on a
envoyé on peut même se demander si c'est
pas effectivement un peu dangereux comme
ça a été dit sur les messages radio qui
partent la vitesse de la lumière
ceci dit la bleue informationnel qu on a
défini autour de nous mais quand même
extrêmement petit en nombre d'années
lumière ça fait très peu de temps qu'on
envoie des signaux l'écart news
évidemment que ce qu'on prête à ces
possibles strattera est il faut encore
revient sur l'anthropocentrisme c'est
nous-mêmes qui exprime on
nous ambiguïté nos craintes nos espoirs
voilà ça peut guère aller un bug guère
aller plus loin et ce qui vient d'être
dit évidemment toutes les questions de
dangereux techniques d'investissement
parce que tout ça les années lumière s
est énormément d'énergie et il faut que
les planètes en question et l'énergie
suffisante et nous savons que l'énergie
est limité en tout cas c'est look à
laquelle nous avons accès et il pourrait
y avoir d'autres si les symptômes et
énergie dans les réflexions de fair milk
qui étaient cités et d'autres
astrophysiciens sait il faut se trouver
au bon endroit au bon moment
s'ils veulent arriver sur votre plateau
à la bonne heure
des voyages qui peuvent durer des années
des années lumière il faut pas se
tromper de créneaux ils peuvent arriver
un million d'années trop tôt ou un
million d'années trop tard parce que
dans l'universel voilà le million
d'années c'est pas grand chose
donc c'est vrai que même en multipliant
le nombre de civilisations possible
faut-il encore que au moment où nous
nous existons où nous nous enregistrons
et bien il est quelque chose
effectivement qui arrive ne serait-ce
qu'un signal donc c'est vrai que ça
multiplie énormément les les contraintes
pour qu' il y ait une rencontre ne
serait ce que de signaler de détecteurs
thierry gaulin oui oui pardon non
j'avais envie de vous entendre rebondir
sur cette idée à savoir
là on parle de temps mais de notre temps
à nous de notre conception du temps est
ce qu'on peut en imaginer une autre
est-ce que où est-ce que effectivement
ils sont ils sont prisonniers des
contraintes et on n'est pas près de les
voir quoi en l'état de nos connaissances
actuelles de 500 il ya des contraintes
que nous ne pouvons pas surmonter
on parlait d'un alpha du centaure à la
vitesse de la lumière il faudrait 4 35
années pour y aller autant revenir mais
on est très loin de la vitesse de la
lumière
après on a parlé de l'énergie dont on
aurait besoin landaise il ya le nom qui
m'échappe a mis un scientifique
d'origine russe je crois qui a établi
une classification de l'accès à
l'énergie pour une espèce par exemple
l'espèce humaine qui pourrait on est on
est très proche en voit en fait d'avoir
d'actia d'arriver au premier rang au
premier niveau de 7,7 accès à l'énergie
c'est à dire l'énergie de toute la
planète après il aller plus loin mais je
pense que monsieur jardin peut
développer ça mieux que moi puisque lui
c'est c'est plus son domaine il a
peut-être continuer le shard à celle et
celle de celles est faible car daf
nicolaï kardashian qui était
effectivement un physicien russe et donc
il définit 3,3 échelle celle de
contrôler en gros l'énergie de sa
planète on va dire ça comme ça
ensuite l'énergie de son étoile donc y
est mais millions voire des milliards de
fois plus grande et puis après l'énergie
de toute la galaxie l'échelle pro après
on pourrait même imaginer
s'il y en a une qui arrive à colony les
et la galaxie que en fait elle elle
essaime ailleurs mais ça c'est quand
même vraiment beaucoup plus difficile
les galaxies étant très isolée dans
l'espace les unes des autres et irrigue
l'invs est fondée il ya longtemps
maintenant une association ovni
languedoc et j'arrivais pas à savoir si
si si vous y croyez vous à leur présence
chez nous ou pas non alors vous avez
compris que chez nous la croyance
semaine ne fait pas partie du phénomène
aérospatial non identifié par contre je
vous dirais un titre personnel si les
extraterrestres débarquent et de
maintenance jardin je serais content ça
y'a pas photo mais en ne raisonne pas en
terme de croyance et ans
on va plutôt raisonner en termes de fait
en termes journalistiques scientifique
éventuellement puisqu'on a quelques
scientifiques dans l'association aussi
dans notre démarche c'est celle là mais
quand vous dites vous seriez content
j'imagine la satisfaction on serait tous
contents d'avoir la réponse soit oui
mais en même temps il faudrait
s'inquiéter non parce qu'ils s'y sont
dans votre jardin
ils ont une supériorité technologique
sur nos pieds tels que a priori ça
risque de mal se passer pour nous
j'entends ça peut effectivement mal se
passer à l'échelle des sociétés humaines
on a constaté effectivement que qu'à une
société possédant une technologie
supérieure rencontre une société qui a
une technologie en retard généralement
ça se passe plutôt mal pour la seconde
y'a qu'a voir un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé aux amériques par exemple mais
peut-être qu'on peut aussi envisager une
situation où la civilisation qui
arriverait avec une technologie
supérieure soit à même de faire en sorte
que tout se passe bien alors que je
disais qu'ils jettent que je serais
content qu'ils soient dans le jardin
bien évidemment si c'est la bestiole
d'ayem là je serai moins contents mais
si ce sont des extraterrestres qui qui
ont envie de prendre contact et qui sont
rationnées jeu moins ce que nous a plu
ce serait mieux d'ailleurs là je serai
content et vous jacques arnould vous
soyez contents même réponse perles
personnellement moi j'ai toujours une
certaine curiosité pour l'autre via une
question qui nous poursuit depuis des
millénaires
donc si on me propose de rencontrer un
autre aussi extraordinaire qu'un
extraterrestre
moi je dit de lui tout de suite un
nouveau comprenant un réalisateur me
l'avait proposé il ya quelques années
dans une fiction avec entrèrent avoir
trois heures de conversation avec un
visiteurs extraterrestres
tout ça était il viendra sûrement de la
fiction mais l'exercice est toujours
intéressant d'être confronté à quelque
chose que vous ne connaissez pas donc
oui cela m'intéresse personnellement
maintenant il ya effectivement le
contexte général et qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour l'humanité dans son
intégrité j'allais dire même
et puis cette planète terre là les
auteurs de science fiction imaginée
quand même beaucoup tina
you dont une partie n'est quand même pas
tout à fait à notre avantage donc là
effectivement on pourrait avoir peur
quand vous voyez le petit film qu'on a
vu au tout début celui qui a été donc
authentifié par le pentagone filmées par
un chasseur
voilà celui qui a fait la couverture de
der spiegel vous vous voyez quoi vous
quand vous regardez ça voilà un point
qui se baladent
mais voyez j'ai essayé de faire
l'exercice en temps mais qu'est ce qu'on
voit exactement parce que je suis censé
être dans un avion là avec un viseur et
comment comment il arrive à suivre
moi ça voilà ça dépasse ma capacité de
d'appréhension la chose c'est pour ça
que je suis un bon ok ça existe mais
j'ai pas de repères c'est pas que vous
savez dans la rue vous vous promenez
vous voyez des choses que je ne vois pas
et inversement parce que nous ne sommes
pas capables et de la même manière il
faut apprendre
vous savez bien si vous connaissez une
région vous allez faire découvrir des
choses que les autres ne voient pas
c'est la même chose là c'est un monde
qui moi mais totalement inconnu vous
pouvez montrer tout ce que vous voulez
ok et là comment il fait pour suivre
regardez rien ne bouge là c'est le sol
qui bouge ça veut dire que lui avec son
avion il arrive je comprends pas donc je
suis désorientés donc j'ai besoin d'être
initié en quelque sorte peut-être qu'un
pilote pourra m'initier michael valiante
vous voyez quoi vous on pourrait voir
plein de choses en fait on pourrait voir
par exemple un plasma on pourrait
effectivement revoir si ça pouvait être
un avion ça a été ça a été déjà
bon étudier après on peut aussi voir un
phénomène qui nous échappe très
honnêtement et et s'assemblent ça semble
aller dans ce sens hier je tiens à dire
que même que sur ses anciens de
phénomènes qu'on compte non cumul depuis
le temps de ce phénomène inexpliqué on
peut avoir deux approches de satin codes
du cirque on peut avoir une approche
quelque part systématique
les scientifiques ont comparé nos
connaissances et on continue à les
quelque part à repousser les frontières
de l'inconnu en partant de nos
connaissances c'est la démarche
scientifique classique et on pourrait
aussi partant de ces phénomènes qui nous
échappe c'est une autre aussi une autre
forme de deux démarches mais qui est
totalement complémentaires continuer à
accumuler des données est allé dans le
sens un petit peu de ce que veulent
faire les américains semble-t-il
et si le trouvait derrière c'est ces
phénomènes il ya des signaux faibles
garder des quelque part est ce que dans
les données que l'on accumule on va
trouver une forme de structure ou de
genre d'information qui se dessine est
ce que il ya un comportement par exemple
qui peut être récurrent est ce qu'il ya
des choses qui peuvent émerger
alors ça c'est un fonctionnement par
émergence j'ai envie de dire il a
convaincu mais une information et on va
essayer sans aucun a priori parce que
des faux pas des fois mais il arrive que
la réalité soit plus dépasse là quelque
part ce qu'on peu ce qu'on peut même
imaginer dire qu'elle peut aller au delà
et bien simplement prononcés données
ayant en lait
en les observant et en les analysant on
devrait pouvoir trouver des choses assez
intéressantes et je pense que si et ça
rebondit un petit peu sur votre question
s'il y avait une forme d'intelligence là
derrière s'ils ont été visités j'ose
espérer en tout cas alors c'est
peut-être une date et une forme de
croyance j'ose espérer
il ya une forme de rationalité dans la
dernière et donc si une forme de
rationalité
j'ose espérer aussi que cela pourrait se
dessiner
justement au travers de cette
accumulation d'informations que
représentent ces observations a très
vite parce qu'il ne reste qu'une minute
gabriel chardin vous voyez quoi vous
dans ces petits films je vois pas grand
chose dans les petits films et sur la
question de l'extraterrestre dans mon
jardin j'aurais qu'un certaine méfiance
celle-ci la rive soit il vient de la
terre est bon donc c'est ça s'explique
pas autre chose soit il vient de très
loin et il est quand même très très
probable qu'il ait une immense
supériorité par rapport à nous au moins
on a certes un sens et donc mais on doit
compter sur sa bonne volonté mais c'est
méfiance quand même thierry go là vous
voyez quoi vous je vois ce qu'on lundi
de voir ce que j'ai dit dans le rapport
dit que je ne suis pas compétent tant
que pilote de 18 ou ssg plus par contre
sur les signaux faibles effectivement et
sur l'accumulation des données les la
tenue des deux dossiers le croisement
d'informations
ça peut permettre effectivement d'avancé
un petit peu les choses sont ainsi tous
les quatre d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]